[Musique]
donc on avait un astronaute dans la
salle
j'espère qu'il n'est pas parti dans les
étoiles non il est toujours là très bien
et bat donc je disais après ces quelques
questions on se rend compte que la
plupart des gens quand on me demande ce
que le faire quand il était petit
c'était astronautes ou bien policiers
photographe
on a vu plusieurs ont déjà aujourd'hui
ou bien artistes on en a vu aussi
aujourd'hui informaticiens ou bien
vétérinaire mais la plupart du temps ce
qu'on va entendre c ou ou ou ou alors
une seule proposition
et pourquoi ce ou pourquoi ce que les
gens sont au ventre à dire ça ou ça ou
ça mais simplement parce que depuis que
vous êtes petit vous est formaté tels
des moutons ou vous explique une vie
c'est un métier un métier une carrière
on parle souvent de vocation de destiner
dans notre culture et on vous demande
toujours la même chose qu'est ce que tu
feras plus tard on n'attend pas
plusieurs réponses on attend qu'une
seule réponse
et ça continue quand on devient plus
grands lors des études on vous apprend à
faire des études pour un seul métier
votre vie professionnelle l essence est
toute tracée dès la sortie de vos études
alors tout le monde suit le même chemin
mais moi je prends cette citation ne
marche jamais sur le chemin tracé car il
ne te mène que là où d'autres sont allés
c'est alexandre graham bell canada
mais moi j'ai pas envie de suivre les
chemins tracés et j'avais pas envie et
un petit dessus les chemins tracés temps
petit j'avais différents rêve un peu
comme ceux qui ont posé des questions de
la salle est un des premiers c'était
faire des jeux vidéo parce que j'ai eu à
l'âge de 5 ans un ordinateur et donc
j'ai appris à faire des jeux vidéo à cet
enjeu programmé mon premier jeu vidéo
mais totalement différent carrière
artistique
je rêvais d'être chevalier et de faire
des trucs historique
eh ben j'ai aussi créé
une troupe de reconstitution historique
qui ont fait des spectacles un petit peu
partout à travers l'europe
mais c'est pas tout moi aussi j'avais
des rêves des espaces et bien là
maintenant j'ai une société qui crée des
simulateurs spatiaux pour apprendre aux
enfants à 1 piloté des navettes
spatiales
mais c'est pas tout je suis également
analystes
infographiste photographe jongleurs
pyrotechnicien maître d'armes des scream
inventeur chefs d'entreprise et je
programme dans treize langage différent
mais pourquoi est ce que je fais tout ça
et pourquoi est ce que je me suis mis à
faire autant de métiers mais simplement
parce que moi je ne voulais pas du tout
étant petit je voulais pouvoir faire ce
que je veux je ne voulais pas être
limité à une seule carrière limité à une
seule vie j'étais opus moutons là parmi
les troupeaux le mouton noir celui qui
fait rien comme les autres celui qui a
d'autres idées et celui qui a souvent
des idées folles celui qui a la tête aux
deux pareilles on dit non non c'est pas
possible
des idées c'est exagéré et bien
malheureusement j'en ai pris pas mal des
murs toujours les mêmes remarques mais
non c'est pas possible
concentre toi sur une étude concentre
toi sur une seule chose et on ne fait
qu'une chose de la vie si l'on ne
réussit pas on peut pas réussir si on
fait plein de choses et tout le temps
les mêmes le même refrain même refrain
même chose tu disperse tu dissiper et
parfois même jusque du mépris des gens
qui ne comprenaient pas mes choix de
carrière et mes envies tout ça
simplement parce que la plupart des gens
ont une vision vraiment très très
stricte de ce qu'est une vie une vie une
carrière à la fois heureusement ça
comment un petit peu évolué mais on se
rend compte que c'est toujours très très
fort présent dans une société
alors cette citation est tracy très
intéressante lorsque tu fais quelque
chose
sache que tu auras contre toi ceux qui
voudraient faire la même chose ce qui
vous est le contraire et l'immense
majorité de ceux qui ne voulaient rien
faire cette situation vous paraît bien
vrai je pense je l'avais déjà rencontré
alors imaginez quand vous voulez faire
des choses à la fois le nombre de
personnes qui vont tous vous dire tu va
dans le mur
la complexité de faire plusieurs choses
de la fin
un des meilleurs exemples c'est le jour
où j'ai voulu créer ma société passées
en entreprise
je suis allé trouver un organisme dette
de de l'étape et je suis arrivé mais
bien gentiment devant le monsieur en le
disant écoutez je fais de la robotique
je fais de l'informatique je fais du
spectacle
je fais du design donc bah voila moi je
suis je suis indépendant j'ai pas
d'argent je vais lancer une entreprise
avec six départements six secteurs si
plan financier et je lance tout ça tout
seul demain le monsieur m'a ri au nez
il m'a dit tant que vous y êtes vous
avez qu à vous appeler universal et
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai appelé ma
société vigo universal et oui bon quatre
ans plus tard je recevais le prix du
trends le journal célèbre belge comme
premières entreprises de belgique
première start-up qui avait décollé il
est clair que cette personne elle avait
tort elle avait tort simplement pourquoi
mais parce qu'elle n'avait qu'une seule
vision des choses et que certainement
dans sa carrière de conseiller
elle a toujours vu des gens qui
voulaient faire qu'une seule chose mais
moi je voulais faire différentes choses
à travers le monde et surtout à travers
le temps il existe beaucoup d'autres
personnes on va faire un petit jeu je
vous donne des as 10 on va d'abord
commencer par quelqu'un du passé
quelqu'un qui fait de la biologie et
ceux qui ont une idée de la salle vous
pouvez déjà levé la main c'est bien on
est dans une université ou sion qui
faisait de la mécanique en plus ce que
j'ai plus de mal vu que deux à dix alors
le troisième si j'ai pas tout les mâles
wc tu as un problème
eh oui léonard de vinci à son époque
faire plusieurs métiers était quelque
chose de normal dans les universités on
vous enseignez à faire plusieurs choses
passons à quelqu'un d'un peu plus
moderne et à devaux même jeu avec vous
les mains levées des batteries ça il y
en a qui ont déjà des mines et un de
l'argent l'argent virtuel on va dire des
voitures électriques
les fusées j'en vois qui rigolent et
puis bon mélange de tout on envoie des
fusées avec des voitures et cliquer dans
l'espace
voilà donc je suppose que vous voulez
tous reconnu ces lots de masques qui lui
aussi fait plein de trucs à la fois et
qui à différents métiers
mais dés gens comme ça il en existe
partout à travers le monde
je vous ai montré des célèbres parce que
si vous avez parlé d'un cousin mais ça
vous êtes juste rien dit mais des gens
comme ça il en existe partout à travers
le monde et qu'est ce qui fait que ces
gens sont unis qu'elle est très commun
qui rassemble ces gens c'est une bonne
question
eh ben ils ont un trait de caractère qui
s'appelle multi potentiel liste on
trouve des définitions sur internet
différentes j'en ai pris une ouazar les
multis potentiel d'un point de vue
neurologique est définie comme possédant
un mode de câblage neuronale différent
de la majorité mais ne sous-entend en
rien une anormalité et ne fait référence
à aucun trouble mental quelconque
en gros on n'est pas méchants on n'est
pas dangereux
on est juste un petit peu différent sur
notre façon de penser
on n'a pas non plus des superordinateurs
de la tête
on n'est pas des machines et on n'a pas
des super pouvoirs
on est des gens comme vous on est tous
pareils on est juste câble est différent
comme disait la définition et on pense
d'une façon un petit peu différente et
vu qu'on a plusieurs métiers on est un
peu une sorte de couteau suisse où on
peut faire plein de choses et s'adapter
à plusieurs situations
ce qu'il ya c'est que nous on donné on a
dû faire des choix dans les a pas fait
de la même façon et quand une personne
décide d'explorer une porte
nous on décide d'explorer toutes les
portes en parallèle et et d'affronter
différents univers possible alors il ya
des forces de ce côté là on est des gens
passionnés dit qu'on fait quelque chose
on est à fond dedans à fond dedans on
compte pas les heures du coup on
s'investit énormément
alors bon il ya des gens qui
s'investissent ordonnant beaucoup de
temps il y en a qui ont beaucoup
d'argent donc du coup ils s'investissent
avec beaucoup d'argent pour envoyer des
fusées dans l'espace
faut de l'argent et puis après on a
aussi un gros avantage qu'ils
apprentissage rapide
pourquoi parce que ce qui fait souvent
peur aux gens c'est quand ils sortent de
leur zone de confort c'est quand on leur
dit tu vas devoir apprendre une nouvelle
matière et ça ça ralentit les gens cela
fait peur nous on apprend toujours de
nouvelles matières donc dès qu'il s'agit
d'étudier un nouveau métier
une nouvelle fonctionnalité ça ne nous
fait plus peur parce qu'on a appris à
apprendre et donc on va beaucoup plus
vite pour apprendre ce qui nous donne en
fait grâce à toutes ces facettes une
large vision sur les différents
problèmes que l'on peut rencontrer essai
de large vision va induire un esprit de
synthèse beaucoup plus facile et donc
trouver l'essence des problèmes beaucoup
plus rapidement on va pouvoir grâce à
tout ça vraiment agir comme des camions
et prendre les fonctionnalités qu'il
faut dans la bonne situation
on fait souvent preuve aussi de beaucoup
de créativité et on sait bien que
l'innovation généralement à levier de
quoi elle vient de plusieurs domaines
différents qui vont se réunir avec une
petite touche de créativité pour
développer de nouveaux concepts et de
nouveaux projets et justement tout ça
nous permet de faire preuve
d'ingéniosité
alors faut pas rêver hein
il ya le revers de la médaille il ya
aussi des faiblesses les petits
problèmes qu'on essaye d'oublier mais
qui sont là on est impatients quand il
s'agit d'étudier quelque chose par
exemple on n'a pas encore fini la table
des matières du bouquin qu'on voudrait
déjà connaître l'entièreté de la matière
on est épuisant or pas pour nous on est
pile ont surtout pour les autres
notamment pour nos collaborateurs qui
sont bien courageux de nous supporter
parce qu'on est déjà en train de
travailler sur quelque chose qu'on pense
déjà à trois choses plus loin et du coup
nous souvent on ne réalise pas pour les
gens autour autour de nous on n'est pas
soi même longueur d'onde et on leur
demande beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
on demande d'aller aussi vite que nous
et c'est pas toujours facile de
supporter des gens comme nous merci à
ceux qui nous supportent
alors on est distrait ça c'est clair
quand vous pensez à cette chose à la
fois vous êtes tout le temps dans les
nuages vous est tout le temps dans la
lune c'est très difficile de rester
concentré sur certains points et puis on
ne supporte pas faire de choix quand on
quand on sait qu'on peut faire plusieurs
choses à la fois pourquoi choisir si on
est capable de faire plusieurs choses à
la fois est notre pire ennemi c'est le
temps parce que c'est lui qui nous
oblige souvent à faire des choix
puis on se rend compte souvent que quand
on fait quelque chose
une fois que le défi relevé on perd
beaucoup d'intérêt pour cette chose et
donc on s'intéresse de nouveau à notre
secteur et c'est très dur de continuer à
faire des choses lorsqu'il n'y a plus
aucun défi et ont donc on passe notre
vie a constamment rechercher de nouveaux
défis pour la vie de tous les jours et
puis il ya la pacte social l'impact
social peut être positif je prends un
exemple mes collaboratrices
elles se sont peut-être pas rendu compte
mais au début quand elles ont commencé à
travailler que moi mais elle était venue
pour un métier et maintenant elles sont
devenues elles aussi multi potentia
liste parce qu'elles font plein de
choses à la fois il ya le fond plein
métier elles ont des tas comme moi et je
me retrouve alors demandé plein de
choses et maintenant elles suivent elles
suivent elles suivent la suite donc un
impact social qui est important sur les
gens qui sont autour de nous et je les
félicite pour leur travail et je veux
aussi remercier cette personne est
minime apnic qui est qui est une
personne qui a fêté dicks aussi et qui
m'a fait découvrir en fait le terme
multi potentia liste j'aime bien je
m'étais bien rendu compte qu'ils avaient
des choses spéciales dans le
comportement dans mon comportement un
comportement de personnes que je
connaissais mais elle a mis un nom
dessus et sa conférence est vraiment
très intéressant donc si vous voulez un
autre point de vue je vous invite
fortement à regarder sa conférence j'ai
aussi réalisé une chose c'est cette
citation qui dit choisissez un travail
que vous aimez et vous n'aurez pas à
travailler à ce jour de votre vie mais
je fais plein de travail différents et
ben je m'amuse tous les jours et je vais
totalement tout le temps tout le temps
du renouveau du changement et je ne
m'ennuie jamais et donc je suis heureux
dans mon travail alors une autre chose
qui est important du coup c'est que tous
les jours j'apprends quelque chose avec
ces nouveaux métiers est pour moi une
journée où je n'apprends rien d'une
journée de perdue donc c'est très
important d'apprendre mais finalement
c'est rien c'est rien de très spécial
c'est comme si vous êtes du sport vous
pouvez vous entraîner et entraînez votre
façon de réfléchir
votre façon de voir les choses tout
comme un sportif de haut niveau va
s'entraîner ou ou quelqu'un d'autre va
s'entraîner vous allez pouvoir vous
aussi développer ses talents
et de cette façon vous aussi apprendre à
dire non je ne veux pas de vous parce
que dites vous bien si ya pas d où ça
veut dire qu'il ya plus de regrets et
voilà on n'a qu'une seule vie mais moi
j'ai choisi d'en vivre plusieurs à la
fois et dans la vie les seules limites
que vous me donnez les seule barrière
que vous avez c'est celle que vous avez
décidé de vous mettre en face de vous
prenez la peine prenez le courage de
franchir cette barrière et vous verrez
derrière des verts pâturages et tout ce
qui peut s'offrir à vous est peut-être
au job de rêve un ou plusieurs qui sait
ce que vous allez choisir ton de
carrière et peut-être que tous ensemble
nous deviendrons comme ceci alors
réveillé le multi porte à ces risques
est en vous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]